So on Tuesday, Donald Trump did this video
screed where he had sort of like conflicting
and confused reasons for which he was threatening
to veto the second coronavirus stimulus package
on Wednesday.
He did veto that package.
And one of the things Donald Trump said he
wanted is a 2000 dollar stimulus check rather
than a 600 dollar stimulus check.
Now, very conveniently, many Democrats, including
our friend Roxana.
Have been talking about thousand dollars per
person for a while, and as soon as Donald
Trump said, I want to grand, many Democrats
said great, let's work together on it, we're
ready to do it.
But the Republican Party has blocked an attempt.
Democrats did move to increase the size of
the checks when Trump said, let's do two thousand
and it is not going to happen because yesterday
House Republicans blocked the attempt by Democrats
to do two thousand dollar payments.
And now we are simply waiting on whether the
House will vote to override Trump's veto on
Monday and whether, if that happens, the Senate
will vote to override Trump's veto on Tuesday.
But it is it's just not going anywhere.
The Republican Party has been arguing for
less and less money.
And the House tried to pass two thousand dollar
payments on Christmas Eve day.
So yesterday during the day, they had a brief
meeting of the House where Democrats tried
to approve two thousand dollar payments by
unanimous consent, which means any one lawmaker
can block it.
It's not a 50 plus or supermajority or whatever.
It is simply any one Republican, any one lawmaker
can block it.
Congressman Steny Hoyer, Democrat, offered
the proposal from the floor and it was blocked
by House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy.
And that is it.
So we there's really no expectation at this
point that that is going to happen under Trump's
watch.
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi said that on Monday
she will do a recorded vote on the two thousand
dollar payments.
But I mean, it's not going to make any difference
at this point in time.
Democrats continue to tell Trump, just sign
the bill and let's I mean, listen, one of
the other problems here is why is the government
funding bill part of the same vote as the
covid stimulus bill?
We know why this is a common thing that's
done in Congress.
The idea is, if you're against a bunch of
stuff one party wants to do, you say let's
join this vote with the stuff we want to do.
You do one, vote for both bills.
And then 20 years later, much like we've seen
happen with Bernie and Joe Biden and others,
when you're asked why did you vote in favor
of Bill A. and you say, listen, I wasn't really
in favor of Bill, I was in favor of Bill B,
but our colleagues on the other side said
the only way they would support it is if we
wrapped it up with Bill.
I found it so important to get the people
six hundred dollars instead of zero that I
conceded.
I said, I'll give them Billey because they're
giving me Bill B, which I think is the right
bill for for helping people.
This is politics.
This is how it always works.
It's disgusting.
There's no actual reason that you couldn't
have one vote on covid stimulus and then separately
one vote on government funding.
But that is the way that they have done it.
And one of the interesting sort of little
details is we talked yesterday about how Donald
Trump has turned on basically everybody around
him, Mike Pence, Mike Pompeo, he's he believes
none of them are supporting him in his bid
to overturn the election results.
Mitch McConnell is also on that list.
And Mitch McConnell has been against more
stimulus for months.
And when it's a conversation about stimulus,
he wants the smallest possible stimulus since
Trump suggested the two thousand dollar payments.
Mitch McConnell has been silent about the
demand for the two thousand dollar payments.
And it is just, you know, who really loses
here?
It's the people.
Right.
And this is why when we talk about political
posturing by either side, when we talk about
all of these different public moves that do
nothing to actually get help to people to
be any closer to a reality, we have to remember
that a bunch of this stuff is almost almost
as bad on the Democratic side as the Republican
side.
So we'll see what happens Monday with the
House vote on overriding Trump's veto.
We'll see what happens Tuesday conditionally
with the Senate voting to override that same
veto.
And maybe by mid-January, payments could be
going to people.
It will take a couple, at least a couple of
weeks.
It is believed once if and when this is approved
for money to get into anybody's hands.
So certainly twenty, twenty one not this is
not going to be twenty, twenty money in the
best case at all.
We've got a great program for you today.
We will be off all of next week.
The show will be off next week.
Just reminding everybody no show next week
and then.
We will be back with you in the new year,
but we still have plenty going on today.
Remember that on January 1st, one one twenty
one, we have a huge membership special going
on.
If you want to be notified about it, just
get on my newsletter at David Pakman Dotcom.
It is this is the type of membership special
people have never even heard of before.
Never mind.
All right.
So get on that mailing list at David Pakman
Dotcom.
Quick break.